I'll mark Bustos and today I'm going to
go over how to achieve the undercut the
main thing with an undercut is the
disconnection in lengths of the hair
between the top and the sides so the
first thing you want to do is to create
a horseshoe sectioning around the top of
his head
usually is right about at their corners
where the hair grows so right where I
make that party I'll just spray the hair
on top a little bit basically everything
that's below this hair on top is gonna
be shaved so today I'm going to use the
Clippers to achieve this look right here
I'm using about a number 3 I'm just
going to go straight up I'm going to
stop right at that sectioning and we're
all the way around the horseshoe section
so once we've established that length on
the top everything below this point is
going to be shorter so basically what
I've done is I created 3 lines so I made
a align with the number three up in
through here and created a weight line
with the number 1 right in through here
and a weight line with a 0 right in
through here so we're going to use a 1
and a half in the 2 to blend that into
there and to blend this out I'm just use
the 1/2 and a 1/2 get into there so
after all of it it's going to be a nice
seamless blend you want to make sure
we're constantly combing the hair down
as we work because the hair moves as you
cut it I'll take a number 2 and go in
between this new line I made with 1 and
1/2 and go right below the number 3 now
go back to the number 1 and blend out
that a little bit of a line that we have
that now that I've done that I'm going
to blend the zero out up into the 1 so
I'll basically use 1/2 staying below the
number one line
this way it gives it a nice seamless
look rather than doing that hard line on
the side works it's gonna go back in
with a zero and just clean up whatever
I've missed and make sure we get every
little bit of hair once I'm happy with
the way the sides came out I'll go on
and whip down the top of his hair the
best way to cut this top shorter back
here to gradually longer towards the
front I want to show you the profile
view of this so you can see what I've
done there is now longer in the very
front I'm gradually shorter towards the
back